that doesn't necessarily mean we would
see fewer deaths but we would certainly
see a lot less of the virus circulating
in the population so I think that it's
up to employers and employees alike to
assess what it is absolutely essential
and is it absolutely essential that
somebody travels for work and and works
outside of the home or is it not and we
all have to act in the absolute best
interests of of the country at the
moment and try and minimize that contact
where possible okay thank you and to dr.
Ellie now and Sharon says she thinks she
may have already had corona virus in
January but still has symptoms now like
a coffin a temperature is that possible
and what do you think she should do
given that we're now at the beginning of
April the unusual for any viral
infection to have continued for that
that length of time so that would
already be three months so it's possible
that she did have something in January
and now she has something else so with a
fever and a cough that could be her own
virus symptoms so I would be isolating
as per the government recommendations
and if she has any breathlessness or any
difficulty with her breathing any change
in her breathing she should be talking
to her GP or using the online
one-one-one scoring system or speaking
to one one one but I think it's unlikely
that she's had the same illness the
whole way through since January okay
thank you um Natalie you now dee has
asked can you catch corona virus more
than once well this specific corona
virus soaked ovid 19 that is unlikely or
certainly unlikely in a very short
timeframe so you develop antibodies to
the virus after you've been infected
with it so if it was a couple of months
later you shouldn't be infected with
exactly the same type of corona virus
again we don't know how long the
antibodies last for at the moment
but there's a good a good estimate of at
least six months to a year and it may be
longer than that so certainly you
shouldn't be able to contract kovat 19
twice in this same epidemic period now
is that based on our dealings with other
coronaviruses or is it based on what we
know about this one in the short time
that it's been around that's based on
what we know of in in other
coronaviruses but particularly in SARS
because this virus is Tsarskoe v2 which
basically it's very similar in its
genetic makeup to SARS but it hasn't
been around long enough yet for us to
know how long the antibodies can last
but obviously there will be data from
China shortly that indicates whether
people have antibodies to the virus who
were known to be infected and how and
whether those antibodies have persisted
for the few months since they were
infected but we're still trying to get
an accurate test to measure antibodies
at the moment so they're all still in
research trials okay any idea when
that's going to come out just briefly in
the next few weeks there there trialing
them already at the moment so if the
data is good they'll be available in the
next few weeks some countries have
already rolled them out okay Natalie
thanks a lot I'm dr. Ellie Hugh wants to
ask you will covert 19 behave like the
winter flu and return at the end of the
year and could we have a vaccine by then
so that goes back to the question that
you just answered so if it stays the
same then people would have immunity
should have immunity in the winter so it
won't be coming back the reason that
seasonal flu comes around each winter is
because they're actually different
viruses and so the flu jab that we use
every year at the moment in the UK
contains I was three or four different
viruses and whereas cope at 19 is one
virus so if it stays the same and it
doesn't new tape it doesn't change then
our immunity should carry on as
Natalie's just described in terms of the
vaccine I think the estimates are
anywhere between six months
to 18 months we have to remember how
much testing and regulation goes into
vaccine and drug production and the
worst thing we could do is to rush out a
vaccine before it's safe okay thank you
so much
um don't go anywhere because we're going
to come back you're watching Sky News
lots more questions for dr. Elliott and
Natalie in a moment see them
[Music]
welcome back to our coronavirus Q&A here
on sky news
we've got Natalie McDermott she's a
clinical lecturer at King's College
London and dr. Ellie cannon who's a GP
thanks for holding on there for us
another question to Natalie and mark
Dunkley has asked do we currently have
sufficient oxygen supplies for the NHS
and sufficient capacity in the supply
chain to fulfil future needs I suppose
particularly pertinent because we just
saw it happened at Watford Hospital and
so certainly at the moment we have
sufficient oxygen supplies for any
patients who are admitted I think where
where there may come a change is if we
have an influx of even more patients
requiring oxygen and it's not that we
don't have a sufficient supply it's just
that we might have to upscale the
manufacturing process in in the UK and
also it's sorting out the logistics of
making sure more and more oxygen
cylinders are reaching hospitals that
need them and also ensuring refilling of
cylinders that are based at hospitals so
many hospitals will have an implicit
astir that supplies oxygen to the wards
for anyone that needs it and so it's
just making sure that things are filled
up regularly and portable canisters are
transported to hospitals as well in case
supplies run low and one would assume
that given what we're facing that is
being done I mean do we have any idea
that it is my understanding is that that
is one of the government's priorities
certainly they have mentioned it in
their news conferences in the last week
that they will ensure upscaling of
ventilators which we've heard of a
delivery of 300 ventilators today but a
ventilator is only useful if you can
also supply oxygen through it you can
ventilate with air but many patients who
are being ventilated may also require
higher levels of oxygen so that is a
priority for the government
where they are at with upscaling that I
I'm afraid I can't comment okay Natalie
thanks dr. Ellie one for you someone on
Twitter has asked people who smoke
cigarettes and e-cigarettes and a
greater risk of contracting the corona
virus than those who don't it's not so
much about being at greater risk of
getting the virus because we're all at
the same risk of contracting the virus
it's how ill you would get if you were a
smoker or a vapor I think it's hard to
say with these cigarettes because
they've just not been around for long
enough and what we always say about
e-cigarettes is they are less risky than
smoking but we don't know yet about
their long-term risks although all the
evidence would point to the fact that
they are much less risky than smoking
even in the long term certainly if you
are a smoker your lungs are not as able
to cope with infections as if you're not
a smoker you would be more likely to
develop a pneumonia and a severe illness
so it is absolutely the time to quit now
when we are social distancing okay I'm
sorry thanks Natalie
Nick asks what I'm sure many people are
asking at what point could the
government decide to extend the current
lockdown and impose further restrictions
so that's a very good question I think
that it will depend on what we're seeing
in terms of the number of people
infected the number of hospital
admissions and the number of deaths so
the government are monitoring that and
if we see that the social distancing
measures currently in place are having a
good effect then in due course the
government might relax some of them but
if we see that actually it's taking
longer for them to have an effect than
we thought it may be that the government
feel the need to prolong the process I
think what's likely is that at some
stage there in the measures are relaxed
but we may then see a surge in cases
again and the government may decide
actually we need to go back to where we
were but the best way for us to shorten
the amount of time that we are in a
sense
in lockdown is for us to all abide by
those measures and ensure that people
our social distancing and then we will
see a decrease in numbers and hopefully
eventually a decrease in deaths and
hopefully a relaxation of the lockdown
measures because it's all about the
modeling isn't it taking the figures
that we have available now and looking
at what they sort of forecast as it were
yes so it's all about trying to reduce
the amount of people who have contact
with one another in terms of the social
distancing and the lockdown the reason
for doing that is to try and reduce the
number of new infections we get from any
one person who is infected if we can
bring that number below one so anyone
who's infected with the virus infects
less than one person then we can
eventually get on top of the epidemic
and that's what the modeling shows very
clearly and we will be guided by the
modeling as to the impact of the social
distancing measures so far but the goal
is to get that number of new cases or
new infections to from any one infected
person to below one okay dr. le Natalie
thank you so much for talking to us this
evening